COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN AND FOR
HIS NAME TO BE BERNARD SANDERS.
REMEMBER, SHE ATTACKED THE STATE
OF ISRAEL REPEATEDLY.
EVEN CAUGHT IN NUMEROUS
ANTI-SEMITISM SCANDALS.
EVEN ATTACKED A SURVIVAL OF
FEMALE GENITAL MUTILATION FOR
CRITICIZING ISLAM.
THAT WOULD BE NATION OF ISLAM
LEADER.
JOINING US NOW FOR A REACTION IS
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY, SARAH SANDERS.
WELCOME ABOARD, SARAH.
>> Sara: WHILE DELL MIGHT
GREAT TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW HIS
THINKING.
YOU KNOW HIS MIND-SET.
I LOOK AT THIS CAST OF
EXTREMISTS, AND I'M LIKE, WOW.
I GUESS THE ONLY ONE WHO CAN
BEAT DONALD TRUMP IS THE
DONALD TRUMP, WHICH I DON'T
THINK HE'S GOING TO ALLOW TO
HAPPEN.
>> NOT FOR A MINUTE.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP, THE REASON
YOU SAW HIM SO HAPPY, SO JOYFUL
TONIGHT, NOT ONLY BECAUSE THE
COUNTRY IS DOING WELL, BUT
BECAUSE IF THIS IS THE BEST THAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TWO OFFER,
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO BE ELATED.
I'M NOT SURE WHY ANY OF THESE
CANDIDATES ARE RUNNING.
THE SEEM TO HAVE SUCH A DISLIKE
FOR THIS COUNTRY, DISLIKE FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY'D WANT TO
TRY TO LEAD.
THE POLICIES AND THE POSITIONS
THAT THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE
PUSHING IS HARD TO IDENTIFY.
HE SEEMS TO BE SO CONFUSED ALL
THE TIME.
I HOPE THAT THIS IS THE BEST
THAT WE HAVE COMING OUT OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY, BECAUSE IF IT
IS, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANOTHER
GREAT FOUR YEARS OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR 2020.
>> Sean: I TEND TO AGREE.
NOT ONLY THAT, THE PRESIDENT,
MORE THAN ANY OTHER POLITICIAN
THAT I CAN THINK OF, HAS
ACTUALLY DOUBLED UP, KEPT HIS
WORD.
EVERYONE, I'VE GOT A LOT OF
CRITICISM FROM CONSERVATIVES,
ONE WHEN HE WAS RUNNING.
I VOUCH FOR HIS CONSERVATIVE
VIEWS.
I THINK HE MEANS IT, EVEN THOUGH
HE LIVED IN THE LIBERAL CITY
LIKE NEW YORK.
AND SECONDLY, PEOPLE SAID, WELL,
THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN UP ON
SECURING THE BORDER.
AS SUCH, NO HE HASN'T.
HE'S SWITCHED GEARS.
HE CAME UP WITH A BETTER
STRATEGY, AND HE KNOWS HE HAS
THE LEGAL JUSTIFICATION, THE
CONSTITUTIONAL JUSTIFICATION
WITH THE REALLOCATION OF FUNDS
FROM THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT.
THAT IS OFFICIALLY HIS.
THE BORDER WALL IS BEING BUILT.
NANCY PELOSI'S COMPLAINING.
SHE COULDN'T STOP HIM.
>> Sarah: EXACTLY PAIRED NOT
ONLY IS THE PRESIDENT WINNING ON
CAMPAIGN PROMISE AFTER CAMPAIGN
PROMISE, BUT HE'S DOING IT
ON HIS OWN.
WITHOUT THE
HELP OF DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS.
THEY SPENT EVERY MINUTE OF THE
PRESIDENT'S TERM FIGHTING
AGAINST HIM.
JUST THIS WEEK, THEY FINALLY
CAME BACK TO WORK, AND THE ONLY
THING THEY CAN DO IS TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE TERRIFIED OF HIS
SUCCESS, BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THE MORE HE.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
HELPING AMERICA.
HELPING PEOPLE ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY.
I'M PRETTY SURE THEY DON'T EVEN
LIKE AMERICA.
IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT THEY'RE
SAYING.
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE TO SAY IS
SO NEGATIVE.
YOU SAW THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
THAT FROM THE PRESIDENT TONIGHT.
I HOPE THAT PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THAT CONTRAST AND SEE
THAT YOU HAVE SOMEBODY WHO LOVES
THIS COUNTRY, LOVES ALL OF THE
CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY VERSUS
THE DEMOCRATS, WHO HAVE NOTHING